it is a story that we've all heard
sometimes too many times before a young
healthy person dying after contracting
covid19 and this time the virus took a
young mom in a matter of weeks now her
husband newborn daughter and the rest of
her family are left shocked and
devastated as they try to move forward
sasha loftus joining us now live tonight
to share their story
denise and brian kimmey was young
healthy and ready to welcome her first
child still covid19 came the virus stole
her away from those who loved her more
than anything
she was wonderful
loving generous and eternally joyful are
just a few words vera foster uses to
describe her sister kimmy just such a
happy loving
would take the shirt off her back for
anybody more than anything she and her
husband longed for a child of their own
and tried for years to live that dream
she finally got pregnant and that's all
she wanted she just wanted to be a mom
but before her baby girl was born covet
19 took hold of kimmy's world and after
weeks of fighting to breathe with oxygen
treatments and ventilators the 35 year
old died alone this week here at spring
valley hospital she never got to hold
her baby that she wanted so long it's
something vena wants no one else to go
through and she's asking for the same
support her family has felt since her
sister first got sick i'm just asking
for that same overwhelming love
to please be there now to help mike
her husband and this little baby
because they're going to need it this is
a lot for him and while kimmy may be
gone her warmth and light will live on
for generations to come i feel when that
day comes and i can hold that little
baby in my arms i'll be holding my
sister
now kami's family has started a gofundme
page to help her husband mike and her
newborn daughter jordan move forward
without her and of course to help with
funeral expenses if you'd like to help
their family we have more information on
our website
8newsnow.com reporting live in the
newsroom tonight sasha loftis 8 news now